up next we got Scott Davis this is Scott
Brennan it's Optio
coming to you from the cowboy state the
big beautiful state of Wyoming and man
my nose is looking like [ __ ]
well okay anyway trade Jeff Brandon I'm
not too far from where you were you from
in Aurora I got family living around but
that's besides the point I gotta dodge
bullets bro guys here's a little
background I work full-time my wife
works full-time and we got two beautiful
little bread Snatchers don't make it to
the gym as often as I would like and I
got that dad buck coming in bro and I'm
proud of it but it's coming in sprout
the hopper bun oh yeah
that's what I got king of sting it dad
butts
dang dude love you dude
shout out to Wyoming my neighbors I love
Wyoming man I've been to Cheyenne before
watched a guy get hit by actually know
what I watched I got jump out of a hotel
room and die commit suicide they say and
uh X was in Montana was he doing all
completely different every moment she
doing for good cause though what was he
doing
no I three freedom I wasn't on drugs
during the day I let it do it I hate
being on drugs during the day dude why
would you do during the day wait for
your nightfall yeah that's when Satan
comes out dad buzz the hopper Bob dude I
feel like I was the hopper bod it didn't
I didn't realize it don't want to catch
with my kid I looked at all the other
dads their shred city sometimes life you
just wake up on more your 273 pounds you
have no idea what happened it's the way
it works it's kind of cool though but
there's difference now hear me out there
there's a difference between dad hopper
Bob and they're just straight-up fat
don't be trying to say oh I get
deference I've had a friend of mine yeah
when you just fat you're fat don't call
a dad bod cuz there's just fat you know
I'm saying oh yeah man I know him please
bro it's all about it's all about your
diet though bro
yeah dude first of all the guy's two
kids he's doing the best he can he's
full-time worker so does his wife right
dude so what I'm saying is this I think
it's okay to have the dad bod if you are
with the kids at the pool you go by
yourself you better get in shape before
you do dude don't be dad bottom with no
[ __ ] kids bro no
all right yeah a lot of guys like Oh got
a dead body's like no dude you're just
out of shape you have any children you
just fell you're fat pot yeah you got
that [ __ ] you don't have kids you're
just fat yeah
or you just have that gristle aeneas
body type you know good luck though
brother the struggle is real for us
dad's out there yeah man so I say with
the kids dad bye yes without the kids
he's just fat yeah you just got to
tighten up a little bit and do some a
teaching dad bods if you really have
kids wear tight clothing or dual onesie
actually that's what I do